good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is a CP 1048 object
class Keter formerly
safe special containment procedures the
following sentence was stricken from the
official document scp-1048 is currently
free to roam site 24 as it poses no
threat and has been observed to greatly
improve the morale of personnel than
interact with it the whereabouts of
scp-1048 are currently unknown though it
is still believed to be somewhere in
site 24 subject is to be secured for
containment but any creation of scp-1048
should be destroyed on site unless
further evidence warrants less extreme
actions no teddy bears are allowed into
sight 24 to prevent any confusion or
mistaken identity any object that
resembles a teddy bear is to be reported
to the security team immediately this is
not a joke we have no idea what scp-1048
full capabilities are who knows how many
of the damn things are out by now dr.
carver description scp-1048 is a small
teddy bear approximately 33 centimetres
in height
through testing composition of the
subject revealed no unusual qualities
that make it discernible from a non
sapient teddy bear subject is capable of
moving of its own accord and can
communicate through a small range of
gestures the subject regularly shows
affection to individuals in ways found
endearing by most people affection is
usually given in the form of a hug to
the lower leg but subject has also been
observed dancing jumping in place and in
two separate events has even drawn
childlike pictures for janitorial staff
all foundation personnel that have been
directed with the subject have responded
positively to its affection even d-class
with normally sociopathic tendencies
attempts at direct communication with
scp-1048 have not been considered
successful though it is capable of
simple gestures to indicate a yes or no
answer it will often not react to line
some questioning concerning its nature
or where it originated from it is not
known if this is because scp-1048 simply
does not know the answers or because it
does not want to answer though capable
of drawing pictures it is not used its
art as a form of communication beyond
showing affection even when encouraged
to do so the more anomalous behavior of
scp-1048 was not observed until
approximately seven months after it was
originally secured it is hypothesized
that the subject is able to construct
crude replicas of itself using various
materials by a process that is yet to be
observed directly by foundation staff
dr. carver has suggested that scp-1048
uses its endearing qualities to lull
those around it into a false sense of
security allowing it to collect
materials to produce these creations
currently there are three known
creations of a CP 1048 designated
scp-1048 a B and C the nature of these
creations has been in stark contrast to
scp-1048 general behavior as all have
exhibited extreme violence towards
humans
scp-1048 a on scp-1048 a was discovered
wandering site 24 accompanied by a CP
1048 subject resembles a teddy bear
similar in size and shape to scp-1048
but is made entirely out of human ears
when this is interviewed reported that
it appeared scp-1048 was giving a tour
of site 24 to scp-1048 a dr. carver was
called to the scene along with his
security team
the security team arrived first and
attempted to contain a CP 1048 a subject
emitted a high-pitched shriek that
inflicted intense pain in the eyes and
ears of everyone within a ten meter
radius ear like growths immediately
began growing on those within five
meters of the subject covering their
bodies in less than twenty seconds every
person afflicted with this symptom died
within three minutes
resulting in death personnel including
the entire security team autopsies
revealed the cause of death to be as
fixed the ancien caused by an abundance
of ear like growths manifesting in the
mouths and trachea of all victims
scp-1048
and scp-1048 a fled the scene before dr.
carver arrived and of not being
contained since the incident though
sightings of bulks have been reported on
multiple occasions
shortly after this incident occurred a
researcher was discovered missing an ear
according to him it was removed through
unknown means while he was sleeping no
other victims of ear removal were found
so it is unclear if scp-1048 obtained
more ears from another source or it is
capable of duplicating objects or
materials
scp-1048 be subject was discovered by
several foundation staff members in the
cafeteria of sight 24 on subjects
appearance was nearly identical to
scp-1048 but it moved in an irregular
jerky manner witnesses reported that it
appeared as if something was moving
inside of scp-1048 be subject made no
attempt to interact initially until a
burst and it seems revealed what
appeared to be the hand an arm of a
human infant poking out and grasping the
air at the sight of this a female
researcher named screamed and scp-1048
be reacted by emitting a high-pitched
cry similar to that of a human infant
the subject then attempted to the
screaming researcher causing massive
internal damage in the ensuing chaos a
security team was forced both the
researcher and a CP 1048 be
approximately three hours after this
incident doctors was found unconscious
and bleeding in her office an abortion
have been performed on her while she was
sleeping and the eight month old fetus
was never found it is hypothesized that
scp-1048 used dr. pol his unborn child
to create scp-1048 be information
regarding the possible origin of
scp-1048 B is not to be leaked to the
survivors currently undergoing therapy
for the incident with scp-1048 B as dr.
Carver believes it would be extremely
detrimental to their recovery scp-1048 C
subject resembles a teddy bear
similar to scp-1048 but composed
entirely of rusted metal scraps subject
was first sighted up by dr. Carver in
his office while writing up a report on
the scp-1048 bee incident subject fled
the room when it noticed dr. Carver
observing it in the attempted pursuit of
scp-1048 see dr. Carver witnessed the
death and maiming of
datian personnel is the subject
exhibited extreme violence during its
escape scp-1048 c has not been
encountered since this initial sighting
and it is unknown whether it still
resides somewhere within sight 24 the
origins of any materials possibly use to
construct scp-1048 c by a CP 1048 are
also unknown at this time
addendum 1048 1
scp-2295 is similar but nearly
antithetical and function to scp-1048
attempts to establish a common origin
are ongoing extreme caution is to be
taken if scp-1048 a or scp-1048 c are
encountered again i cannot stress this
enough the damn thing jumped right
through those poor people
dr. Carver well that's not creepy ok
that about does it for today thank you
all for listening and you are all
dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bashar Muslim Mookie Jax
Merrick Pierce M Hamlin Austin Thomas
Aldridge
Desmond Hoskins Depp's McGee
dr. mortis Johnno Porter
Judi Dench Tiber ball on sighs seven
actual if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash evolving thank
you
[Music]
[Music]